blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
let's start with the most fun possible
segment
we ever do which is a review
of where we are with the coronavirus
pandemic i know it's really a party um
we we haven't done
a review of covid cases and deaths
lately because it's just been so busy on
the show but now in the context of
some declining vaccination and uh
changing mass
guidelines which we will get to this is
worth doing i believe we are now
three weeks from a massive reduction in
covet cases
and just a little more than three weeks
from a massive reduction in covert
deaths now keep me honest on this this
means may 19th
three weeks from today i've marked it in
the calendar i believe
coveted numbers will be looking really
good in the united states and we're
going to come back and see if that
actually uh
happens let's start with cases and then
we'll talk about what's going on so to
begin with as a reminder the u.s has had
essentially
four case spikes the first was that
first
spike in march of 2020 the second in
july of 2020 summer of 2020
the third and the biggest in the winter
of 2020
into january of 2021 and then as cases
started to come down rapidly
during the vaccination phase in february
and in march
cases kicked back up a little bit why
did this happen well it's believed that
it was because
some people started going nuts too soon
even though they weren't vaccinated
and then also we had that british
variant the b117 variant
in the northeast of the us in michigan
and a few other places
and it was actually starting to outrun
vaccines
we seem to have turned that around case
numbers now coming down in michigan
it now seems we've vaccinated quickly
enough
that we are back into some semblance
of control in what is big picture and
out of control situation
remember that the vaccines work well
against all the variants to some degree
less so against the south african
variant but still
does does well uh cases are now down
about 20 percent
from that mini peak a month ago so from
that little peak we're already down 20
percent
we're down 78 in cases per day
from the big peak in the middle of
january
that should continue down now the death
curve
the death curve has been more nuanced
but it also
didn't really experience any resurgence
in the past couple of months even though
cases went back up deaths did not
deaths peaked in late january around
3 400 per day just an incredible
horrifying number they are now down to
about 725 deaths a day still terrible
but continuing to decline we are down
about 80 percent in daily deaths
but 20 of that peak is still a lot the
death decline can take longer because
i mean quite morbidly it takes time to
die from covid
so there are people who have been sick
for a while who will continue to die
even as more people are protected by the
vaccine people who would have died
in june did they not get vaccinated
today
it takes a little time to see the impact
of that but by memorial day hopefully
death numbers will also be really low
now unfortunately
these case and death declines are coming
as we are seeing reduced vaccination
numbers this is not because of the
brief pause to the johnson and johnson
vaccine it is not because there aren't
vaccines available this is
increasingly a demand issue after a long
period of vaccination
increasing all the way up to an average
of three and a half million doses per
day
we were hoping we would get to four or
even five million doses per day
we did not we are now back down to 2.7
million doses per day
continuing to decline only 2.1 and 1.7
million doses per day in each of the
last two days
there are lots of vaccination centers in
blue states red states north south
everywhere saying
you don't need an appointment just show
up and get a vaccine
we should soon see approval of the
pfizer vaccine for people age 12 to 15
hopefully moderna as well that will add
people
uh to the demand but we are getting to
where more and more of the people that
want a vaccine have gotten it or at
least a first dose waiting on a second
so we are now going to need new
initiatives to encourage people to go
out and get the vaccine today i will be
talking
about joe rogan's recent anti-vaccine
comments which i find very dangerous
many of you wrote to me about them
saying david why won't you criticize
your friend
joe rogan all right well we're going to
do it today it's very dangerous we do
not need things said now
that will encourage people not to get
vaccinated so that will
yes i will talk about my friend joe
rogan we will talk about it today
but even if we can keep doing 2 million
doses a day
we're still going to be looking quite
good by the middle of june
and that's where we are today this stuff
matters we now have as i told you
earlier
more relaxed or as rather as i i told
you yesterday
we would get and we will discuss in
detail later today
i realize it's unclear to say i told you
earlier i told you yesterday and now we
have the the new guidelines
we have more relaxed mass guidelines
because
people have been getting vaccinated
because the vaccines are so effective
at the same time we're nowhere near out
of the global catastrophe i'm putting up
on the screen the chart the case chart
from india
which we discussed on a previous show
and it is a disaster
people are literally dying in the
streets in india a video
came out of two sons
on a motorcycle transporting their dead
mother
uh holding her upright on the motorcycle
because
all services she died of covid all
services are collapsing in india
even in canada cases have been spiking
and things have not been looking so good
so this will be a continued
and long global process which will
hopefully look much better
in some countries as soon as a few weeks
from now
we're going to get to the masking we're
going to get to the vaccination later
but that's where we are on cases and
deaths to shift gears
a little bit before we get back to covid
stuff as we discussed many times during
the presidency of donald trump
the humiliating and cartoonish nature of
trump led to many of our historical
allies being distanced from the united
states
uh canada france germany others the us
was increasingly not a part of major
global discussions on important issues
climate of course being
one of them why on earth would a
trump-led united states
be part of climate discussions when
trump said climate change was a hoax
created by the chinese allies talked to
each other
but they increasingly did not involve
trump and the united states
and the reputation of the u.s was in the
toilet a toilet that trump was flushing
10 to 15 times remember that
our reputation was in the toilet and
exactly as predicted
the reputation of the u.s is coming back
quite quickly
i got a lot of phone calls during the
transition period from trump to biden
saying do you think we will recover our
reputation quickly and i said
i think we will because much of the
world is eager
for a non-cartoonish president and the
u.s popularity has improved
significantly in several countries since
joe biden took office
this is data from the latest morning
consult poll looking at the list of
countries
our standing abroad has increased
dramatically
in germany where our favorability has
almost doubled from 24 to 46 percent
germany is followed by japan and france
where our favorability has gone from 36
to 55
and 29 to 46 respectively now to be
clear
these are not exactly stellar numbers
despite major improvements
37 percent of germans 22 percent of
japanese 29
of french see the us negatively never
mind other countries
like canada 47 of canadians
see the united states negatively but the
point is
what is happening in the real world
actually does get paid attention to
and it has an impact abroad it's not uh
capricious negativity about the united
states
trump out and favorability increases
significantly
now anecdotally americans are also less
stressed
day to day because the president the
former president
uh was always at risk of making some
horrifying
blunder and unleashing global shame and
embarrassment upon us
we no longer worry about that as
important as it is to realize
that our reputation does respond very
directly to who is the president and to
what the president is doing
it's also important to realize that this
could happen again
most republicans still like trump most
republicans still believe trump won in
november
if you can believe that and most
republicans would vote trump back
today if given the chance despite the
successes of joe biden
in his first hundred days vaccination
coveted stimulus
rehabilitating to some degree the global
reputation of the country
i'm hearing from friends and relatives
in a variety of countries including
france belgium
argentina where i was born israel it's
primarily a feeling of relief that trump
is gone
and relief gets you part of the way but
it doesn't get you all of the way
back to a recovery in reputation sadly
most of the world understands what in
this country
nearly half of americans don't
understand which is
it's objectively bad for us and everyone
else to elect
an incompetent buffoon like donald trump
it really shouldn't be done again
but it might be if they get a say
and if they're able to suppress the vote
enough in 2024 remember
they didn't suppress it enough in 2020
they tried but they failed
if they succeed at voter suppression to
a greater degree in 2024
trump could be back or someone like him
now lastly
just because joe biden is restoring our
reputation to some degree
and doing good things doesn't mean bad
things don't still happen
uh they do and we have to keep paying
attention which is exactly what we're
doing
in a sense boring politics is good but
it can lead to complacency as a result
and
that is exactly how donald trump ended
up coming to power nah he has no shot at
the republican primary oh he won the
republican
primary well there's no way that he can
beat hillary i don't even know if i'll
vote
because it's just not going to be
necessary to uh um
defeat donald trump oh trump beat
hillary well then
what boring should not mean
we don't pay attention but it's okay for
it to mean
less constant stress about which rights
is the president trying to take away
from
people or media or from whomever
we are going to continue following the
reputation of the united states around
the world
much improved in many countries but
nowhere near where we should want to be
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
at d pacman and boy do we have a good
show for you today i act
i think we should actually uh record and
keep today's show
which is not what we always do because
today's is actually a pretty good one
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
hey remember to grab those memberships
we've been seeing some massive
dumps of new memberships lately people
taking advantage of the secret
unpublished coupon code
immoral 21. it is an immoral coupon code
but it's
it's certainly not illegal we've
confirmed that you can use the code
on the membership of your choice at
joinpakman.com
the vaccines work so well and enough
people have gotten them
that the cdc has announced
no more outdoor masks in most situations
for vaccinated people now if that sounds
underwhelming
or if your reaction is you know most a
lot of the countries already been doing
that
these guidelines of course are for
people who are following cdc guidelines
if you've not been following them all
along
then you don't really care what the cdc
says you're probably not getting
vaccinated either you're probably
you probably have been letting it rip
but for those of us who care what the
cdc says
and who have been following uh joe
biden's uh
agreement with cdc guidelines remember
these aren't biden's guidelines they are
just joe biden saying i will listen to
what the health experts say
the cdc yesterday announced that
outdoor mask wearing really is not
necessary
in most situations now it's very
carefully written
americans who are fully vaccinated
meaning two weeks
after your last dose whether it's one
dose or two doses two weeks after the
last dose at least actually with j and j
maybe longer
if you're fully vaccinated against
coronavirus you no longer need to wear a
mask outdoors
while walking running hiking biking
alone or
in a small group including with members
of your own household
masks are still necessary in crowded
outdoor venues like sports stadiums
that's what the cdc
has said joe biden coming out and
announcing the same thing
the cdc stopped short of saying if
you're vaccinated you just never need a
mask outdoors
they say that it's still conceivably
possible that you could transmit
coronavirus
and that with unknown vaccination levels
in crowds
it's safer to wear a mask even if
vaccinated in a big crowd now
i think this makes perfect sense
unfortunately there are some doom and
gloomers
who are furious and we were live
streaming joe biden announcing this
yesterday and i had people saying
david you can still pass it even if
vaccinated well
yes you can but uh transmission is
reduced by more than 90 percent
and outdoors it's almost zero
pre-vaccination
dr rasheesh jah believes one out of a
thousand cases were transmitted outdoors
that's before anyone was vaccinated
uh you were really talking about
percentages and a risk level that is
lower than the flu when you're talking
about an increasingly vaccinated
outdoor situation i've been following
the guidelines so even though from the
beginning i thought
i if i'm biking on the bike path i don't
need a mask
but after getting some dirty looks yes
the judgment worked on me
and i put the mask on when biking or
when running or whatever um we are now
being told very clearly by the cdc that
certainly at least vaccinated people do
not need
to do that now the cdc director rochelle
walensky
emphasized a bigger interpretation
than the narrow wording of the cdc
saying quote we no longer feel that the
vaccinated people require masks outdoors
other than large public venues period
and
uh one really interesting thing is that
the cdc
has also put out a sort of pictograph
that shows a list of activities the risk
level if you are unvaccinated and the
risk level if you are fully vaccinated
the risk level for fully vaccinated
people is color-coded green meaning low
risk for every activity
including going to crowded outdoor
events
the venue and the recommendation may
still be to put a mask on in that
situation even if vaccinated
but the cdc making clear if you're
vaccinated the risk level
for a big concert is low the risk level
for going
inside at restaurants is still low now
of course it will continue to be lower
as more and more people are vaccinated
if you individually have a higher risk
profile
then that may not be something you want
to do right away and we're going to talk
about that later
in my segment about joe rogan's recent
comments but
hopefully the point here is that
hopefully this will
encourage more people to want to get
vaccinated
that is increasingly an issue that we
are dealing with in the united states
while many countries are still having
major
supply issues with vaccines in the u.s
increasingly the problem is lack of
demand uh
it's it's actually tragic so many
countries desperate to get vaccines they
haven't yet been able to get
in the u.s more and more states are
going to just show up
you don't even need an appointment and
they're still not filling every slot so
hopefully the word from the cdc and
biden
that the masks can come off for
vaccinated people
in almost every scenario will encourage
more people to want to get vaccinated
the counterpoint is if you still don't
want to get vaccinated you probably
don't care what the cdc says about masks
and that certainly
uh is a source of concern let's now talk
about some of the
reaction from the media to joe biden's
announcement
of what the cdc has determined regarding
masks
this is probably my favorite joe biden
moment from his presidency thus far and
it came
during yesterday's white house event
where outdoors
at the white house joe biden announced
the cdc has new guidelines we have been
vaccinating enough and the vaccines are
so effective
that masking outdoors is no longer
necessary for vaccinated people in most
situations this was a great announcement
this was really a sign of progress
and joe biden did walk out to that event
wearing his mask he took it off to speak
and he announced masks are no longer
necessary outdoors for vaccinated people
he was a vaccinated person outdoors
taking off his mask and peter alexander
from nbc news
was just desperate you could see
desperate to generate controversy
i've talked before about how in the
absence of
real scandals the likes of which we saw
during
the trump administration under biden
reporters
even reporters that generally are just
asking good questions
they are just beside themselves to
figure out
some controversy some gotcha against joe
biden
so peter alexander from nbc news eager
to ask a question about joe biden's mask
joe biden first putting on his
sunglasses not his mask
and saying he will take a couple of
questions one at a time
i uh one at a time so then here is the
question from peter alexander
uh sir you came out with a mask
but you're saying masks aren't necessary
explain that isn't that a double
standard
isn't it why would you wear the mask if
the announcement is that they're not
necessary here is joe biden's answer
and you chose to wear a mask sir you
chose to wear a mask you chose to wear a
mask as you walked out here
what message were you sending by wearing
a mask outside alone
and watching me take it off and not put
it back on till i get inside
do you have any this is just hilarious i
mean
well when i came out with the mask i
hadn't yet announced
the new mask guidelines i took the mask
off and announced them and now i'm not
putting the mask back on because i've
explained why to the american people
it's just so petty and so embarrassing
and then fox news reported on the
question being asked
like asking biden about this and
noticing his mask
is some kind of hypocrisy this is now
fox news after the event
saying oh yeah lots of people were
noticing that but he didn't do
he he walked from the white house alone
wearing the mask to the podium
and of course it was something we
noticed right away and now yeah of
course you look at your social media and
it's
what everyone's talking about just
overjoyed
they are over at fox news about
peter alexander a reporter from another
network just kind of being made a fool
of
just having a gran they really got him
there didn't they
and the other thing is that even the
framing of all this is wrong
the lower third on fox news during that
clip
was biden relaxes outdoor mask
guidelines biden has done nothing the
cdc
has relaxed outdoor mass guidelines and
joe biden listens to the public health
experts
this is not a trivial difference between
the trump administration
and the biden administration trump would
often
come up with his own ideas that had
nothing to do with public health
official guidance
on masking on maybe injecting bleach on
would a flu vaccine deal with
coronavirus remember that beauty towards
the beginning of the pandemic and on and
on and on
biden has done nothing biden has just
announced
hey great news because of what we've all
been doing together
vaccinating ourselves and so on the cdc
has now been able to announce this and
i'm glad to let you know that this is
what they've decided the whole framing
is off
the forced laughter in the clip clip is
deeply bizarre
everything about this is strange and
pathetic now the other totally
hypocritical
and transparent thing is all this time
they've been saying don't make me wear a
mask
which really they should be saying to
their governors not biden remember joe
bide it's up to
joe biden passed a federal mass mandate
in the sense that it applies to federal
buildings
and federal employees and so on and so
forth governors at the state level
decide on state-level mass mandates
the cdc makes recommendations joe biden
can amplify those recommendations but
it's really governors
but you've got these people who've been
saying do not make me wear a mask
now that joe biden says hey great news
the cdc is now okay with no more masks
outside
for vaccinated people in most situations
they're still not happy now the problem
is well why did biden wear his mask on
his way out to say this
the last guy wondered aloud about
injecting
or drinking bleach and they're making
fun of joe biden
for wearing his mask to a mask-related
announcement
as i've been saying for weeks now when
these are the controversies
when this is what fox news is focused on
joe biden is probably on the right track
in terms of just keeping his head down
and doing things and avoiding scandals
do we want him doing more things of
course
do we think everything he's doing is
perfect no of course not
but when the scandals are so pathetic
fake news about meat eating and
plant-based beer
uh on and on jill biden and joe biden's
relationship
is stage managed whatever when those are
the scandals
he's avoiding real scandals that's for
sure
we will have more on the new mask
guidelines
and again there are people in the
audience that are mad about the new mass
guidelines
uh they seem eminently reasonable and
they aren't that you can't wear a mask
if you want if you if you aren't
vaccinated the guidelines are still wear
a mask
outdoors and even if you are and you
just want to wear a mask you can it's
sort of like
my example from the tucker episode if
you want to wear a winter hat in the
middle of summer
go ahead and do it um i think that these
are eminently reasonable
new guidelines and that they will
hopefully encourage some more people to
get vaccinated
we'll have reaction from you on our
instagram account
follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show
we'll take a quick break the joe rogan
anti-vaccine claims
coming up next the number one funding
source for the david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today okay so i'm going
to criticize something joe rogan said
on his show about coronavirus vaccines
recently but because of the emails i've
been getting i first want to say a
couple of things first of all
i haven't been avoiding criticizing joe
rogan because i've been on his show or
because of some loyalty to him i'm not
doing this segment
in secret hoping joe rogan never sees it
i am not
uh irregularly in touch with joe we've
been in touch a couple of times since i
was last on
everything i'm going to say here i would
say to joe if i were back on his show
this is a disagreement about the vaccine
we would be able to talk together about
it and everything would be fine it's not
some weaponized hot take
or call out i haven't avoided criticisms
of joe rogan more than i have of anyone
else
i just don't watch much stuff when
people send me something from his show
or others i look at it
the dan crenshaw example from a few
weeks ago as an example
so let's just jump right in joe rogan
made statements on his show about
vaccines that i believe are dangerous
in what they are encouraging people to
do and
the risk that they discount if they
follow joe rogan's advice
is significant and it has to be
addressed so let's look at the first
clip and we'll jump right into this
and people say do you think it's safe to
get vaccinated i've said yeah i think
for the most part it's safe to get
vaccinated i do
i do but if you're like 21 years old
and you say to me should i get
vaccinated i go no yeah
are you healthy are you a healthy person
like look
don't do anything stupid but you should
take care of yourself you should
if you're if you're a healthy person and
you're exercising all the time and
you're young
and you're eating well and like i don't
think you need to worry about this
yeah i tend to agree with you this is
not about
you worrying about getting covered if
you were 21 and
you don't want the vaccine when we say
the vaccines are 92 to 95
effective that means 92 to 95 in some
people they are less effective
joe's thought process is only about the
21 year old
evaluating their own risk but what about
the risk of others
i don't have to give you a hypothetical
my dad has a type of blood cancer called
multiple myeloma
they recently did a study of vaccinated
multiple myeloma patients in them the
vaccine is 50
effective it's one study but they took a
group of
vaccinated multiple myeloma patients
two weeks after their second doses they
checked their antibodies
half of them did not develop antibodies
so my dad got vaccinated i got
vaccinated my 17 year old sister
vaccinated right we all did it
but at some point things will go back to
normal you won't need
masks in grocery stores or at the car
mechanic
or wherever else so masks are done
the 21 year olds don't get vaccinated
because they follow joe rogan's advice
my dad goes to the grocery store and
some 21 year old who didn't want to get
vaccinated
uh spreads it to my dad it's not some
hypothetical
of oh i need a mask on the bike path you
all know
i'm not big on the outdoor masks i never
thought we needed them except in rare
big crowds
this is the vaccine cuts down your
ability to
spread the virus by 90 it reduces the
amount of virus that is in the systems
of vaccinated people
my dad has a 50 shot of being immune
with the vaccine he did everything he
can he got vaccinated
but he goes to the grocery store or the
dmv and it's filled with 21 year olds
that hurt joe rogan say if you're 21 and
healthy you don't need to be vaccinated
well
it's not about your level of risk
necessarily
it is about you as a 21 year old as a
non-vaccinated person
could be infected and incubating with a
large viral load because you're not
vaccinated
and then you spread it to other people
the vaccinated 21 year old has a reduced
ability of spread 90 percent reduced
that protects my
dad and the five to eight percent of
people who get vaccinated but do not
develop immunity it is not just about
the 21 year old now
if you don't care about others if you're
the 21 year old
and all you care about is yourself okay
but
it's dangerous to say that that's the
only calculation
if you understand the importance of
considering other people living in
societies the principle at play is
if you aren't likely to die yourself
maybe don't get vaccinated that's what
joe rogan is saying it doesn't work
most people individually are not likely
to die from the virus
if we went by that we would never get
anywhere close to hurt immunity
let's continue yeah i tend to agree with
you but there's a lot of jobs that will
tell you you need to have this well
that's what's starting to happen
people are worried about them doing it
for their children and we talked about
this earlier there's
that that you might have to have your
your children vaccinated
and you know i can tell you as someone
who's both both my children got the
the virus it was nothing i mean i hate
to say that if someone's children died
from this
i'm very sorry that that happened i'm
not i'm not in any way diminishing that
but i'm saying
the personal experience that my children
had with code was nothing
so again same issue about his kids
versus his kids spreading it the longer
this goes
the more the spread is shifting to
children so it's not just about the kids
it's about other people that the kids
might spread it to people who might be
vaccinated
but could be in the five to eight
percent who don't develop immunity or if
you're immunocompromised it might be
more like 40 or 50 percent don't develop
immunity and then also this thing about
vaccine requirements
you know schools have required vaccines
for decades that's just an aside we've
dealt with that before
i don't feel the need to go into to that
too far uh
but there's nothing new or unique about
vaccination requirements for schools
let's keep going one of the kids had a
headache the other one didn't feel good
for a couple days
like maybe i mean not feel good like
like
no no big deal no coughing no no no achy
no like in agony there was none of that
it was very mild
it was it was akin to them getting a
cold yeah and you can have this thing
where it's like you were saying this
virtue signaling
and this kind of like theatrical display
of i get the vaccine what a good person
i am i care about everyone but you're
like look
my daughter's a lot younger than your
kids but i'm like yeah i'm not injecting
my daughter with something to [ __ ]
virtue signal
right i'm not doing that right if
there's something that she's of no risk
statistically has no risk from i'm sorry
i'm not taking
any experiment uh on her in that and
that's that's
my attitude but it's amazing that's
controversial yeah the reason that it's
controversial is that it's based on
nonsense and
ignorance i am right there with the fact
that there is some virtue signaling in
theatrics around covet guidelines
i have said the masks outdoors
when you were walking on the bike path
or passing someone on the sidewalk i
have seen no
evidence that it was ever necessary to
wear a mask in that situation
i'm not interested in virtue signaling i
am not you know one of these lockdown
lovers that people on the right like to
say shut everything down forever no
when two weeks ago vaccinated joe biden
and
vaccinated kamala harris were on a stage
together outdoors
alone with each other and they both wore
masks while the other spoke
i said there is no reason for that maybe
you do it
for theater so that other people see it
and maybe they behave more safely
there was no reason for that but
vaccinating people not at risk
themselves to protect others is not
virtue signaling it's not controversial
it's just caring about humans
then this other guy also says you know
an experimental drug the vaccines
listen if you don't trust mrna vaccines
for some reason
there's no reason not to but what i'm
saying is if you don't trust mrna
vaccines
there are so-called regular vaccines
available for the virus like the johnson
and johnson vaccine
oh but david the blood clots 1 in 1.2
million
all women age 18 to 48. their kids are
not in that group
okay if you don't want an experimental
mrna vaccine then you get the jnj we
there's there's an answer to that as
well
let's watch one more clip that even
saying that i'm not going to inject my
child
with the vaccine is controversial it's
crazy
because again we are not talking about
even the flu
that we just found out killed 22 000
people last year we're not talking about
that right
we're talking about something that is
not statistically dangerous for children
but yet people still want you to get
your child vaccinated which is crazy to
me
like you should be vaccinated if you are
vulnerable
i actually don't know why the focus is
on they want you to get your child
vaccinated because the vaccines aren't
even approved for kids yet now at some
point
after rigorous testing that's ongoing it
might be soon the vaccine or multiple
vaccines might get approved for younger
kids
it's not even approved right now so this
is
genuinely disheartening to see i have no
issue with rogan
personally i'm glad to talk to him
anytime if he wants to have me back on
i'm not saying anything i wouldn't say
to joe if i spoke to him i'd say joe
i'm worried about this for the reasons i
just outlined
i don't assume that he's doing this
because he's a bad person because i've
seen no evidence he's a bad person
i think he's just mistaken and uh it's
it's not sensible commentary
and because so many people consider what
joe rogan says to be gospel
i am worried that lots of the 20
something year olds in rogan's audience
will hear this
and say yep that's why i'm not going to
get the vaccine i'm a healthy 21 year
old just like joe rogan said
and unfortunately that is a recipe for
never
getting out of this in a serious way if
you care about other people
this is not good advice mathematically
medically statistically
and i'm glad to talk to joe about it
anytime tonight
joe biden will be delivering his first
joint uh address uh his first address to
a joint session of the house and senate
but it's not called the state of the
union address often in a president's
first year
the state of the union is just not
called the state of the union and
sometimes it's not
um in february or january it's coming
in april and we will be live tonight on
youtube twitch and facebook
with joe biden's first address to a
joint session of the house and senate
we now have learned that tonight joe
biden will propose a 1.8 trillion dollar
plan
which will include national paid family
leave
universal pre-k free community college
subsidized child care and a whole bunch
of other things now
will it pass as proposed tonight of
course not
of course not it never does that's the
same with every president this is the
starting point
but joe biden will be introducing his
american families plan
tonight it is part two of the so-called
build back better economic agenda
there's
the two trillion roughly infrastructure
and jobs plan that was released earlier
this month
this is now going to be the next piece
of it a 1.8 trillion dollar
package it is being called a
generational investment in the future
it is billed as something that will help
us compete with china it will transform
the u.s economy and it includes
1 trillion in spending over the next 10
years and an additional 800 billion
which would be targeted tax credits for
middle class families
the proposal also includes
cracking down on tax loopholes used by
high income tax filers
um joe biden wants to nearly double the
capital gains rate from 20 to nearly 40
percent for households making over a
million dollars a year
i don't think that's going to happen but
it's nice that he's proposing it
uh 225 billion dollars for national paid
leave another 225 billion for child
care and of course republicans have
already been criticizing it
they will be against it in their
rebuttal tonight to joe biden speech
they will come out against it
what's my thought about this i think
that it is a very
reasonable initial framework we've
talked before about oh but how will we
pay for it
first of all that's never asked about
how do we buy missiles
it's never asked about how we pay for
war it's never asked about how we pay
for tax cuts for the rich
it's asked by republicans when it's
actual
programs that they believe are either
wasteful
or that go to people who are undeserving
in some way under this umbrella of
the morality that they apply to who
deserves
something from the government of course
they're going to be against it
our new framework for understanding debt
and deficit
is that not every dollar of debt is
created equal
if we take on a dollar of debt to give a
really rich person
a tax break statistically most of that
money they save
just sits in a bank account with a
relatively low economic multiplier
if we accrue a dollar of debt
in order to give somebody a better
education which allows them to earn more
later in life
paying more taxes into the government or
if we take on a dollar of debt
to give someone health care that doesn't
otherwise have it so that now
they can get um a pre-emptive treatment
preventive treatment rather than going
to the doctor when they are already sick
and then they miss fewer days of work
and earn higher wages
you understand how there are stimulative
reasons for the government to deficit
spend
and less or un non-stimulative reasons
the framework here is that most of this
stuff
would have a higher economic multiplier
than just tax cuts for the rich
now do i think that this is going to
pass as proposed there's no way in hell
there's no way in hell because even
democrats
are not unanimously on board here with
the things
that joe biden is going to be proposing
so i think that
joe biden is very well positioned right
now
with the success of vaccination the
passage of the 1.9 trillion dollar covet
stimulus joe biden
has a lot of political capital right now
we've been wondering how is he going to
choose to spend it
and it is going to be on this 2 trillion
plus now 1.8 trillion dollar package now
the the i am not looking for i
i think i'm committing we'll see i think
i'm committing
not to deal with the really predictable
right-wing opposition
which is where are we gonna get this
four trillion dollars it's just like i'm
tired of it i'm tired of it i've done
deep dives on exactly where we can cut
spending i've explained modern monetary
theory
and the reality about how a country's
debt is not the same as a household debt
we
we've done it all so if they're going to
just come out and say
uh we just we don't have the 4 trillion
and we can't keep quote printing money
i'm so tired of that maybe i'll address
it in passing
but i'm not going to address that in
detail i'm more interested
in hearing from republicans good faith
critiques
of why the spending specifically
is not a good investment in the future
of america like actually tell me
okay he wants to do free tuition on
community college
why is that bad it seems to me that it
is number one
a great alternative for four years to
four-year schools for people
for whom maybe that's not the best fit
it is a great feeder
to reduce the total cost for people who
ultimately do want to go to a four-year
school and earn a bachelor's degre
degree it seems economically stimulative
it will make us more competitive
tell me why it's a bad idea to spend
money on that rather than just throwing
at me what 4
4 trillion where's biden getting it come
on that's pathetic that's flaccid
it's a very uh flimsy criticism so
i'm hoping to engage more substantively
with criticisms that are made in good
faith and that are not just the same old
thing we've heard time and time again
that's tonight joe biden will announce
it
i will be live starting at 8 p.m eastern
on youtube
twitch and facebook and i hope you'll
join me for that speech tonight
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show okay let's jump
into a few other things
here uh sean hannity the fox news host
and propagandist
friend of trump he's refusing to say
whether he has been vaccinated against
covet 19 and i have some thoughts as to
why he's doing this
so we're going to listen to this this is
audio from sean hannity's radio program
i think that to some degree hannity is
in a weird place now where he's kind of
depressed that the guy he cozied up to
for four years
lost and is out of power and
increasingly people are no longer paying
attention to hannity either so i think
there's there's a bunch of things
going on but let's jump in here listen
to sean hannity and talk about why he's
saying
everybody knows about masks right
everyone knows about
social distancing everybody knows the
vaccines available pretty much now to
anyone
if you're over 16. everybody knows what
level of risk they want to take look
my attitude is if you you know do your
studying
know the science to the best that we can
even say we have science involved in any
of this
so so you know that's kind of that aside
where
they love to throw in the idea that
because our understanding of certain
aspects of the virus have changed over
the last 14 months
can we ever really trust anything that's
coming from the scientific community
and this is part of this is part of the
virtue of science
that science has science is a process
that is self-correcting
where there are rewards for correcting
information that previously we
misunderstood
um and and in fact that should make us
trust more in the process okay let's
continue
because they've gotten so much wrong the
great dr fauci has been wrong so often
okay so maybe i should have played that
first before mentioning but again
the fact that fauci early said one thing
about masks
but then for the last 12 months has been
saying the same thing
that's not a reason to discount what the
medical science community tells us
and the only thing i would ask everyone
is to be considerate
of other people especially older people
those with compromised immune systems
comorbidities
yeah grandma grandpa mom and dad and and
if by that he means
even if you are not at high risk get
vaccinated to protect them then i'm with
him i'm not sure if that's what he means
so that if you know at this point i
would assume that they're probably
vaccinated
they used to have the opportunity to get
it if they didn't if they
that's another thing why do you have to
answer the question well have you gotten
your vaccine yet which vaccine did you
get
how about it's none of your business how
about what do you well i mean
you don't people it's called making
conversation it's also
i mean listen right now if my friends
want to gather
indoors i ask if they're vaccinated and
i say
we're only doing indoor stuff with
vaccinated people right now
other than various you know unvaccinated
but work from home
because i'm vaccinated okay it seems
like a responsible question to be asking
you can decline to answer
you mean you're not going to get
vaccinated how about that's a choice
between an individual and a doctor
i'm very pro-science i'm not
anti-vaccine but i'm also
medical i also am a libertarian believer
in medical privacy
it's unbelievable everyone wants to know
medical privacy
applies to practitioners and it applies
to
uh records and uh it's not about
nobody can ask i mean essentially
you know he he's almost saying you
shouldn't even be able to be allowed to
say how have you been doing lately
met this is not what medical privacy
means it's like everyone now
i'll tell you i probably would have told
people my decision
until everyone started demanding that i
tell them what my decision is
well my advice to everybody yeah is
research
long and hard on on
everything you can get your hands on and
you can read the medical literature
then i would look at your special and
unique
medical conditions see this this is
really stupid
because first of all it's not really
that difficult to figure it out
secondly looking at your specific
situation is again the kind of joe rogan
thing from earlier of if you're not at
risk maybe you don't get vaccinated and
if you read everything that's out there
as he suggests
a lot of what's out there is
anti-vaccine trash
and that's what a lot of his viewers are
finding on their facebook accounts
your health uh and talk to the doctor
doctors that that take care of you or
again sure ask your doctor
most people don't need to have a
conversation with their doctor about
whether they should get vaccinated
doctor doctors that you respect in life
and make an informed decision
and that is that that's got to be an
individual decision
and there are there people that have had
reaction to the vaccines
yup should you read about that too yes
you should read it all yeah i i think
it's
good to understand the level of risk
with with getting vaccinated which is
extraordinarily low
and in all cases lower than the risk of
getting the virus but that's fair
you should know that you know one in 1.2
million of the people that got the jnj
women age 18 to 48 had a blood clot um
maybe if you're in that group you opt
for a different vaccine if that's a
degree of risk that concerns you that
that's i agree with that
no i'm not how do i how can i possibly
weigh in on whether everybody needs to
be vaccinated
i don't know people's individual medical
conditions that is not my decision
that's your decision you have the right
to make
your own decision you can take whatever
level
of risk you might want to take i just
ask gently
think of other people and especially the
those that would be more susceptible for
the worst outcome in all of this
so some of what he's saying is okay but
then also you know
when his refusal to say i would have
told people my vaccination status
until everybody started asking that to
me
sounds like a cop-out where sean hannity
was vaccinated he doesn't want to say it
because saying it will anger the
anti-vaxx people in his audience
much more than not saying anything will
anger the vaccinated people in his
audience it just feels like a
calculation to me
and interestingly this isn't that
dissimilar from what donald trump did in
the sense of trump
was vaccinated at the white house in
january
he didn't mention it he said nothing and
then months later went out of office he
said oh yeah i did receive it or it was
rev it was
announced by his office that he received
it at the white house
it it strikes me as a calculation more
than it is about so-called medical
privacy
but really strange stuff happening over
on the hannity program and bottom line
i think hannity's kind of depressed that
his guy is no longer in office and
people are paying a lot less attention
to him than they used to be he's getting
no more rides on marine one
uh but make of it what you will
pharmaceutical company pfizer says that
an oral drug for covid19 could be ready
next year
pfizer is working on two antivirals an
oral
medication and an injectable the company
started an early stage clinical trial of
the oral drug
last month the drug blocks a critical
enzyme that the virus needs to replicate
it's very interesting here is pfizer ceo
albert borla talking about this this
morning on cnbc
around the summer and what do you think
is a reasonable timeframe albert for
a small molecule antiviral pill like
that to get through phase three and
actually to get out there and
potentially be available
if all goes well
if all goes well and we implement the
same speed that we did so far and we are
and if regulators also do the same and
they
are i hope by the end of the year
in this next clip they talk about the
oral versus the injectable
and again this is albert albert berla
ceo of pfizer who made 18 million
dollars in total compensation
in 2019 uh let's listen uh albert
there's a
in a new york paper it's the post nearly
but covent cure may be ready this year
from the pfizer drug and it's a i know
you know which one i'm talking about
pf zero seven three two one
three three two is what it says but it
it prevents a replication of of covet in
the nose and and
it could be an oral medication and
they're calling it a cure could be ready
next year
is that headline accurate
well it is accurate that we are working
in
uh antiviral and we have an actual on
two
one it is injectable and the other one
as you said it is an
oral and particularly the intention is
on the oral
of the world and of us because provide
several advantages and one of them is
that you don't need to go to the
hospital
to get the treatment which is the case
with all the injectables so far
but you can get it home that could be a
game changer
the compound that you are talking about
and you said very well the numbers
it is a protest inhibitor the good thing
it is that
this is also the first molecule
that is coming from this type of
class this is good thing because you can
combine it
with other classes also the mechanism of
action it is such that
it's not expected to be subject to
mutations particularly because it's not
acting on the
spike as we all know all the mutations
that we are
hearing right now are changes in the
proteins of the spike
so this is not a trivial detail an
antiviral
like what is being developed by pfizer
would not be
as jeopardized by mutations and variants
that's really important
and of course if all goes as described
and there's still much to be determined
here
this could be a real game changer now i
have to tell you
it is not lost on me that as albert
borla is speaking
the stock price of pfizer is on the
screen as their ceo is talking about
medications they may soon have
this is a really stark reminder of the
system that we have and i have addressed
this before
i believe there has to be a middle
ground here on the one hand
we can't allow pharmaceutical companies
to hold us hostage when it comes to our
health
on the other hand i don't expect the
best and brightest minds
to line up to solve our problems as a
charitable contribution i just don't
expect that to happen
the creators of these um
treatments vaccines etc should be
rewarded they really have done something
incredible
the turkish couple in germany who
developed what is now
called the pfizer vaccine they
make a profit by doing this
they will then be likely to do it again
and they will be more likely to come up
with other cures treatments vaccines
when the next pandemic comes around
if there is no profit now who will
invest
next time for now pfizer has increased
revenue about two percent
after investing about 10 billion
researching the
um vaccine they took some risk
of investing in a coveted vaccine they
could have done oncology stuff which has
higher profit margin
okay the same applies to the researchers
the founders of biontech
are now really wealthy but don't we want
people to enter the field of science and
develop things that can be life-saving
but
we need to ensure access we need to look
at government subsidies
and there there's a concept in health
care where
premiums can't exceed benefits by a
certain percentage
or a portion of the premiums have to be
refunded to the consumer
maybe allowing pharmaceutical companies
to have a margin that's
fair but limited would work i don't know
i i'm just thinking out loud there are
certain people
i don't mind seeing being paid
handsomely
right my kid if i had kids my kids
teachers and doctors firefighters
people develop developing vaccines to
deal with a pandemic
should the government be involved in
determining a fair price yeah maybe so
but context is crucial here uh bernie
sanders made a statement about this and
he made a statement about vaccine
production and delivery
outside the u.s and allowing other
countries to use the ip the intellectual
property of u.s companies to make
vaccines and
instead of having to wait around for the
u.s companies those are great ideas
the government should be involved but in
a sense
i am more pleased with people involved
in biomedical research making money than
in some other areas now does the ceo
deserve 18 million that's a very
different question
and uh one that that i think we can
fairly
debate and um you know the counter is
always well if you only pay two million
then some uh mining company will swoop
them up sweep them up instead of
a pharmaceutical company and maybe the
pharmaceutical company will be slower
and
okay okay there's maybe a debate there
but
i think that the the it has to be a
middle path here
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
i think this is a republican caller
explaining why
educated republicans are abandoning the
republican party let's listen
you know it's easy to see why
educated people are abandoning the
republican party it drove
and by the way this is not jimmy from
philly i know the accent is similar this
is not jimmy from philly
david uh it doesn't take a genius to
figure out
that um when john kennedy
asks stacey abrams what a problem is
with voter suppression
he's just assuming that everybody is as
stupid as he is
right he doesn't realize that
smart people aren't stupid and that
he's a stupid person and so
right stupid people can't call smart
people
stupid and
expect them to hang around in their
clubs okay
stupid right smart people are
sick of being called stupid by
republicans
so obviously they're not going to stay
in the republican party
wow okay i think i get it maybe
uh but what is true is that uh educated
voters
are leaving the republican party to a
greater degree okay good i think we've
sorted something out maybe but maybe not
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about west virginia giving
hundred dollars savings bonds to young
people who get
vaccinated a florida mcdonald's is now
paying people 50 dollars just to show up
for an interview
why we will discuss it and a man has
been charged with infecting
22 people with covid after going to the
gym and work
with active symptoms not in the united
states
could this happen in the u.s we will
discuss that and much more and preview
tonight's
live stream of joe biden's speech on
today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinedpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show we have the beautiful
coupon code
secret coupon code on our website for
membership discounts
immoral 21 all one word all lower case
immoral 21
sign up i will see you on the bonus show
and then hopefully tonight for the live
stream as well
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman